tonight is the final vax nevada days
raffle drawing the last round of winners
including the grand prize winner of one
million dollars gets announced announced
at six o'clock this evening we have
hector mejia live this morning in our
newsroom with a look at the other final
prizes on the line good morning hey
there john good morning to you well
we're going to start with the 1 million
dollar prize that is the big talker this
morning plus 250 000 100 000 50 000 25
000
underneath that we also have tuition
money and phishing licenses this is the
raffle incentive we've been telling you
about launched by the state to get more
people vaccinated the initiative
launched back in june and it ramps up
tonight five million dollars total in
cash and prizes nearly 2 000 winners
nevadans 12 and older with at least one
dose got automatically entered into the
raffle so today at 6 pm officials are
coming down to the las vegas convention
center to make the final announcement we
recently caught up with an elementary
school teacher elizabeth alder who was
the first to win the largest prize at
the time back in july which was two
hundred fifty thousand dollars
i've never won anything like that in my
entire life
i've gotten grants for school and things
like that but nothing personal
um i didn't think it was even imaginable
that my name would have been called
so it was i was completely shocked
if you're wondering what she'll be doing
with the 250 000 aside from buying
school supplies and saving some for
retirement she says she's also going to
buy her parents a car you'll hear a
little bit more about that and also
we'll go over just how much the state
has been giving out so far still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now